[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec vous c'est figaro live et on attend
vos points de vue sur la question du
jour qui est posée sur le site du figaro
depuis la mi journée pensez vous qu'un
troisième confinement serait respectée
on posera aussi la question ce soir à
dominique reynié bonsoir denis conçoit
patron de la fondation pour l'innovation
politique dernière étude en date la
souveraineté économique
entre ambition et réalité se retrouver
notamment sur le site de la fondapol
face à vous alexis boisé bonsoir
directeur des rédactions du figaro le
figaro qui revient demain largement sur
le débat autour du confinement et
aujourd'hui on revient aussi sur l'éveil
a fait hier par marine le pen qui est
créditée dans un sondage de 26% des voix
mais surtout d'être en premier au
premier tout d'être en tête
si le premier tour de la présidentielle
avait lieu aujourd'hui faut-il y croire
qu'elles sont ses chances réelles et
telle une machine si sûr à faire gagner
ses adversaires et ses adversaires
serait-il vraiment crédité du score qui
est prédit dans ce sondage
on attend vos analyses on attend vos
points de vue mais d'abord après le
variant anglais le variant sud africain
en attendant le variant brésilien une
question y aura-t-il un variant français
qui s'appellerait jean françois
delfraissy liste n'est pas dire de
secret c'est un peu la blague qui
circule aujourd'hui un jour le conseil
scientifique et son président demande un
confinement du rhin autre jour le
président du conseil scientifique le
conseil scientifique disent que c'est
urgent mais que ça peut attendre
alors on a du mal à suivre c'est un peu
pareil avec le gouvernement mais en tout
cas selon bruno le maire on pense que
les français ne vont pas être très
patient je vais d'abord observé qu'on a
demandé énormément d'efforts au français
guillaume durand un sentiment que c'est
tout ou rien qu'on passerait d'une
situation où rien serait imposée aux
français à une situation leur
confinement global mais c'est pas ça la
situation
ça fait des jours que les français ont
un couvre feu de 18h c'est très
pénalisant
c'est très dur à vivre c'est très dur à
vivre avant 2100 c'est très dur à vivre
pour le monde économique c'est très dur
à vivre pour tous les français
or cet après midi le président de la
république lors du forum virtuel de
davos cette année a dit que ça allait
durer cette situation tous les cas le
coronavirus la présence du virus allait
durer des mois des années peut être un
commentaire sur sur le fait que le
président de la république est déclarée
il déclaré ça ce que ça veut dire que
emmanuel macron essaye de refaire passer
le message qu'il faut vivre avec le
virus etc si je crois que la réponse est
dans la question oui oui évidemment
parce que si les choses devaient
s'arrêter dans quinze jours ou dans
trois semaines ou dans trois mois on
pourrait dire on prononce blanc contours
ferment tous l'obsession de matt damon
est macron depuis le début c'est
d'essayer autant que faire se peut de
limiter les conséquences négatives même
désastreuses pour l'économie impact pour
l'économie pour la la vie des gens pour
l'heure leur vie mentale leur santé
mentale leur santé au cours de deux ce2
évidemment pour l'économie de ce
confinement et de ces couvre feu et de
toutes ces restrictions
donc il vit dans cette obsession là et
vous disiez ça va durer des mois ça fait
maintenant on a un peu de recul et on
voit bien comment se dessine des choses
depuis maintenant des mois et des mois
on sent que à chaque fois qu'ils le
désirent apprendre il ya des camps qui
se forme dans un camp il ya toujours et
c'est pour ça que ce soit une logique de
fonction le ministre de l'économie qui
lui dit retardons le moment le retard
dont le mans on va fermer
le président de république est là c'est
autant de fonctions qui me semblent son
tempérament parce que par tempérament il
est dans la dynamique la marche en avant
et l'idée de serre mais de créer deux
verrous sur l'activité et sur la vie des
gens ça lui déplaît et dans le camp d'en
face il ya le pré ministre qui s'appelle
dont philips ou jean castex c'est
finalement toujours la même position
matignon et toujours pour prendre des
précautions et toujours plus de
précaution le ministère de la santé est
instable donc généralement de hauts
responsables de la santé que ce soit
seul jérôme salomon green lacombe et
delfraissy alors qui c'est vrai varient
mais pour des raisons politiques quand
il sent que le camp d'en face et prendre
le dessus
puis charles decant mais où on a ces
deux camps qui se dessine à chaque fois
et les décisions qui sont prises sont le
fruit d'un arbitrage d'un rapport de
forces des deux camps qui représente
deux tendances qui sont aussi légitimes
c'est à dire qu'il ya le camp finalement
qui met la santé avant tout et la santé
publique et le nombre de morts est la
contamination est mêlé maintenant qui
est comptable aussi d'autres choses qui
est comptable de la vie économique et
comptable de quelque chose comme l'âme
de ce pays et qui dit attention ne
peuvent pas tous fermés tout le temps
dominique il ya eu des nouvelles nuits
d'émeutes encore aux pays-bas contre
justement c'est les mesures qui sont
prévus dans ce pays consécutive donc au
virus est-ce qu'on assiste à un tournant
d'europe
est ce que c'est ce qui risque de se
produire en france on arrive de toute
façon à un moment où il ya et je crois
que chacun leur sort il ya une usure une
fatigue avec la meilleure volonté du
monde c'est pénible
ça devient très pénible et donc la
logique de la situation et je suppose
que présentant un public qui pense avec
acuité la logique de la situation
maintenant c'est de rentrer dans la
phase de la gestion de la pandémie ou le
consentement mesure de confinement ou de
couvre-feu va aller déclinant ce sera de
plus en plus difficile
donc c'est fini la lan sort de la
première période qui a quand même duré
longtemps dans laquelle on trouvait la
force le courage
de se confiner et c est là maintenant je
crois que c'est terminé donc on est dans
une phase qui suscitera plus de
réticence d'opposition de désobéissance
il ne faut pas que ça craque vous savez
ce sont des ddd
on voit très bien comment ça peut partir
avant on peut partir passant à partir si
vous avez une espèce de de propagation
de la désobéissance les cafés s'ouvre et
j'en ai assez je plus chez eux à bout
des gens se mettent à se réunir et c'est
avec un masque peut-être mais c'est sa
part comme ça en tournée sans cela vous
pouvez pas poursuivre tout le monde avec
procès verbal l'ordre le respect de
l'ordre le respect de la loi ça repose
sur une acceptation sur une convention
c'est pas la police qui fait respecter
la loi c'est que il ya suffisamment de
gens qui considèrent qu'il faut la
respecter et la police est là pour
rappeler par sa présence qu'il faut la
respecter
mais s'il est vraiment les gens ne
veulent pas le respecter a aucun moyen
de faire respecter la loi on l'a vu
d'ailleurs absolument mais quand même un
petit peu dans la sphère du gilet jaune
ça devait de plus en plus difficile de
rétablir l'ordre
quand trop de gens sont pour le désordre
et on peut très bien demain fait qu'ils
vont avoir deux restaurateurs on le sent
un petit peu dès qu'ils disent manon si
tout le monde dit non si les gens vont
le sortir dans la rue
qu'est ce qu'on va faire il ya vraiment
là la police l'a pas leur tirer dessus
donc il la question de l'accès pts en 10
maintenant acceptabilité le fait
accepter par les populations
ces contraintes c'est vrai que plus ça
dure plus c'est compliqué plus on sent
que c'est dit c'est difficile moyens il
ya un indicateur que je suis qui n'est
pas un sondage mais qui quand même qui
n'intéresse nos auditeurs nos
internautes puisque c'est la question
qu'on pose quasiment tous les jeux
échanger sur le dos dans le temps figaro
on demande aux internautes du figaro ou
alors c'est pas tous les français
enfin c'est quand même 25 au 26 millions
de francs c'est différent tous les mois
donc c'est quand même beaucoup de monde
on a en ce moment des réponses qu'ils
attendent 200 mille personnes donc c'est
pas du sondage s'est pas représenté
mais ça veut dire quelque chose et je me
autour au début de la pandémie il ya un
an
quelle que soit la question mais des
compositions faut-il fermer faut-il
prendre des précautions faut-il confiné
faut-il faire un coup c'est toujours oui
à 80,81 10%
et puis on est passé à 60 % et puis
maintenant lors du deuxième confinement
est maintenant là quand on demande aux
gens est ce que vous êtes pour un
troisième continent
alors on verra s'il
idée ça peut faire évoluer une fois que
c'est fait on est moins contre enfin
quant aux barrages en est ce que vous
êtes pour un troisième confinement on a
deux cent mille réponses je répète c'est
pas un sondage mais ça veut quand même
dire quelque chose sur 200 milles ça
doit être du 60 qui est contre et 40 qui
est pour quelque chose comme ça oddo
qu'on voit très bien que l'opinion la
trouve que c'est bon ça dure c'est long
et parfois se pose un peu des questions
quant à l'efficacité de son deux mesures
la question qui est posée justement
aujourd'hui c'est pensez vous qu'un
troisième confinement serait respectée
dans la rue puteaux un pronostic qu'on
demande du figaro et pour l'instant les
internautes du figaro pense que à 62%
que troisième confinement ne serait pas
respectée alors il ya une question qui
est posée notamment par certains
internautes
est ce vraiment un confinement si les
magasins les écoles et les entreprises
restent ouverts à ce que ses modalités
la juste nommé comme le deuxième
confinement finalement rendent la chose
la situation accès à ses voisins 10,4
enfin c'est ce que vous dit tout à
l'heure en évoquant les propos du
président sur la pandémie avec laquelle
il va falloir il allait falloir vivre
moi je crois que ce qu'on va devoir
commencer à réfléchir à comprendre
ensemble c'est que on ne verra pas avant
longtemps le retour à la situation
antérieure
on est en train de changer de société et
on va être dans une société est exposée
à la pandémie pendant de nombreux mois
peut-être même des années parce qu' il
faudrait avoir un spécialiste des
vaccins ou du traitement thérapeutique
pour fonder ce que je dis mais la
logique des choses c'est que ou bien on
a une vaccination dans ses effets
durables et on peut à ce moment là à
voir une grande politique planétaire
planétaire parce que c'est pas
planétaire ça sert à rien planétaire de
vaccination et que 8 milliards à
vacciner ou bien le virus sans cesse var
circuler parce que nous sommes là des
sociétés ouvertes on l'a vu avec la
vitesse vocation du coc vide 19 feux
variant au numéro 2 d'ailleurs numéro
deux et donc ça c'est quelque chose qui
je pense n'est pas encore rappelé dans
les esprits nous allons devoir vivre
avec ces
dixième de mesures demi-mesure un peu de
vaccination peut être un peu de thérapie
pendant pendant beaucoup de temps et
peut-être même pendant très longtemps je
sais pas comment on peut dire qu'elle
est le terme de cette crise est-ce que
c'est pas les nouvelles conditions
historiques qui est la nôtre désormais
avec des moments plus ou moins plus ou
moins intense mais ça paraît quand même
difficile d'imaginer une sortie de la
pandémie à quoi à moyen terme même de
briser le moral je veux tout j'espère
que j'espère que je me trompe mais je
lis beaucoup
depuis maintenant je dis beaucoup
beaucoup de choses surtout ça et je suis
frappé de voir que plus vous l'avez vu
comme un vous savez plus virus circule
plus devient performant on a bien vu ça
et donc on peut pas encore le début de
l'année espère enfin mais sans l'outil
on peut encore écarter tout à fait
l'idée que la vaccination produisent une
immunité collective qui nous protègera
quitte à la recommencer tous les ans
mais après tout on peut le faire pour la
grippe je bats pour qu'on le ferait pas
pour le pour lever 19 oui et si jamais
cette vaccination permet de 2,2 faire
face aux différents variant est
semble-t-il le fait que ce soit une
technique nouvelle qui est celle de la
rn qui permet de reprogrammer les
vaccins ne sont pas des souches qu'il
faut chaque fois cultiver mais c'est au
fond c'est l'informatique
si donc on arrive à reprogrammer les
vaccins mais y compris que les souches
qu'il faut cultiver tous les arts
cultive des nouvelles souches de la
grippe
donc moi j'ai en tout cas si j'ose
espérer qu'on sera un
j'espère un de ces jours ce débarrasser
de deux de cette affaire vont peut-être
mais peut-être que vous avez raison
qu'on le sera pas enfin quoiqu'il raison
de plus en tout cas pour apprendre à
vivre avec
dès aujourd'hui c'est pour ça que si
tant qu'on peut parce qu'on voit bien
qu'il ya deux façons de voir les choses
et ce qu'ils disent ferment tous par
précaution mais c'est ce que disent
certains le plus tôt on fermera le mieux
ce sera pardon moi je pense que le plus
tard on fermera le mieux ce sera parce
que tu as on fermera et six ascensions
ferment plus tôt on reverra plus tôt et
ça repartira derrière pour les raisons
qu'on vient de dire oui donc tout le
temps qu'ils aient gagné le temps de
liberté le temps de vie le temps
d'activité économique
le temps de guérir la tête à tort qu'ils
fixent qu'il faut qu'ils font qu'il faut
qu'il faut gagner et donc
peut-être que contre on peut convaincre
confinera et c'est ce que vous disiez il
ya plusieurs degrés dans l'acte dans le
confinement il ya les nuances de gris ou
les nuances de confinement est donc et
le confinement ont fermé écoles et pas
et les confinements ont fermé mais
certains magasins et pas les magasins
essentielle et il ya mille façons de
confiner et je pense que plus moi je
suis je m'élève contre cette idée qu'il
faudrait tous fermés tout absolument
tout de suite pour l'arrêter oui bien
sûr que si on ferme tout de suite on
arrête mais dont conviendra mais ça
reviendra donc
ou alors on se dit qu'on aurait tout
tout de suite jusqu'à la fin des temps
ça me paraît pas la solution
donc il vaut mieux essayer de retarder
tant qu'on peut la compréhension de la
situation c'est que la pandémie est dans
la sinon pour toujours pour longtemps
sas a exclu les confinements en fait en
réalité c'est la conclusion c'est à dire
que puisque ce sera présent en lambeaux
mal de temps il va falloir trouver des
modalités moins lourde moins coûteuse
pour près de protéger la santé des
personnes il me semble que le régime
ordinaire va être un confinement allégé
avec lui masquer la distance et il
faudra bien trouver une solution pour la
restauration est par ailleurs il ya
aussi indifférente parle toujours du
vaccin mais aussi avec des recherches
sur le traitement qu'ils vont continuer
l'alma non plus ne peut pas non plus
exclure qu'un médicament permettre sinon
d'éradiquer en tout cas de le rendre
moins l'était loupe à l'étal du tout
après tout une maladie qui ne fait pas
de mort bon bah c'est désagréable mais
on peut vivre avec donc il ya cet aspect
là qu'il faut pas non plus absolument
absolument investi sur sur 7
cette solution qui a été utilisé par
trump qui coûte 2000 euros le traitement
et donc l'allemagne a acheté des
milliers et des milliers de traitement
pour éviter les formes graves du coup
j'ajouterai qu'un paramètre dont on
parle plus du tout musulman d'étonnant
c'est la question de la taille de nos
hôpitaux nos équipements hospitaliers
notamment de l'est d'urgence parce que
on a tous compris que le sujet c'est un
c'était un rapport entre le nombre de
cas graves dans les urgences et le
nombre de places dans les urgences alors
il faut limiter donc de cas graves mais
il ya aussi un autre moyen d'améliorer
les choses c'est d'augmenter le nombre
de places dans les urgences tout je ne
je ne comprends toujours pas pourquoi on
ne parle pas de ça et pourquoi on ne
décide pas de continuer après tout on
nous a dit au début oui on va le faire
en trois mois d'accord mais on six mois
peut-être qu'on paie puis maintenant ça
fait un an peut-être quand même un peu
et puis peut-être qu'en deux ans on
pourra enfin ça me paraît sous oublier
cette dimension-là de la question qui
est de dire ayons plus de lits
d'hôpitaux pour éviter l'encombrement
des hôpitaux éviter que des gens meurent
parce qu'on n'arrive pas à les soigner
ça me paraît quelque chose qu'il faut
pas non plus oublier c'est une question
qui est soulevée
peut-être pour rebondir à ce que ce que
vous dites justement sur ce débat là
parler par les internautes qui
s'en prennent beaucoup conseil
scientifique là dans l'eure dans leurs
commentaires en demandant quelle est la
légitimité du conseil scientifique est
ce que justement là aussi il n'y a pas
un problème de il ya des questions plus
ample et ffp2 pendant très longtemps on
a plus parlé des masques ffp2 honda beau
début on pouvait plus avant de masques
ne pouvait pas avoir de masse qui
n'était pas fsp 2 après il faut fallu
avoir tout le monde et tout le monde
devait avoir d un masque on a plus parlé
du ffp2 là l'un des instances sanitaires
parle du ffp2 et donc il ya un débat sur
faut-il avoir la fft ou pas est-ce que
quand même il y avait un problème de
d'avoir de multiplication des instances
sanitaires et du confiscation du débat
sire que tant qu'une instances
sanitaires a pas parlé d'un d'une
solution peut pas en parler je sais pas
si c'est clair aussi ces trois mois soit
très clair la carte et que vous avez à
montrer que c'est très confus croit que
sa situation est chose comme ça mais le
au fond le rt dans la couche en fait la
situation est confuse et vous avez vous
l'avez montré clair mais c'est ça c'est
devenu c'est ça que je voulais mais non
mais une citation d'un film de lelouch
je vais maintenant s'étendra aux
internautes de retrouver le film pour
dire qu' il ya une difficulté
effectivement systémique si je puis dire
de ces deux dotés de systèmes va dire
que c'est quand même des sujets sur
lesquels il faut parler réfléchir en
tout cas et que des conseils des gens
qui savent il ya des histoires de virus
etc
il faut il faut il faut absolument qu'il
ya un conseil scientifique alors
légitimité elle est là par rapport à la
question d'un internaute qui savent de
quoi ils parlent
ça veut pas dire qu il maîtrise tout
puisque c'est un virus qui est nouveau
qui mi temps etc et les vaccins même
sans son nouveau et ouvre une nouvelle
page d'ailleurs des traitements médicaux
donc il ya une connaissance et un poids
n'est pas encore tout à fait maîtrisée
parce que tout ça est très mouvant c'est
une chose que d'avoir un conseil qui
conseille en politique c'est autre chose
d'avoir un conseil qui décide qui décide
et qui s'exprime dans les médias c'est
être compliqué la combinaison de la
parole politique de la parole
scientifique c'est peut-être là qu'il ya
des réglages à faire alors je dis y'a
y'a qu'à faut qu'on
c'est compliqué mais enfin peut-être
quand même que la présence est
absolument indispensable après dans la
parole publique
il est préférable qu'elles soient plus
rares et plus ferme si c'est possible et
plutôt politique que scientifique
mais on a vu depuis le début de la crise
du coc vie d'une flopée de médecins
envahir les chaînes ils sont plus
nombreux que les politologues
oui c'est vrai ils sont pas d'accord
mais les médecins et les scientifiques
n'ont jamais été d'accord entre eux
il faut pas non plus sans absolument
sans la renier c'est la vie et ça a été
fait qu'après tout des médecins et des
scientifiques prennent en compte
exclusivement en tout cas quasi
exclusivement l'aspect médical et
sanitaire de questions on peut pas
absolument leurs projets ce qui parfois
me paraît reprochable c'est quand les
politiques abdique leur pouvoir de
décision entre les mains de ces
scientifiques et parfois on a tendance à
penser et peut-être que ce pour des
raisons tout bêtement
comment dire judiciaire que l'ensemble
des responsables politiques craignant
des conséquences elles sont réelles à
ses conséquences dire que effectivement
quand on si on se met à la place du
premier ministre si elle n'a pas misé la
santé oms ce niveau là j'ai plutôt
intérêt à me retrancher derrière l'avis
des scientifiques comme ça quand viendra
les inévitables contestation judiciaire
de mes décisions
quand viendra l'inévitable cour de
justice parce que ça viendra ben moi je
pourrai dire à vous écouter les amis
j'ai écouté les les savants et donc vous
pouvez rien vous pourriez me reprocher
j'ai fait tout ce qu'on me disait alors
moi je suis blanc bleu donc donc je
reconnais que c'est pas facile mais je
crois malgré tout que la responsabilité
des politiques c'est de savoir faire la
part des choses et essayer de trouver le
juste équilibre entre ces questions de
santé mais que des questions qui vont
qui sont la santé mais au delà de la
santé qui sont l'économie qui sont la
santé de l'âme d'un peuple qu'ils sont
sont sa santé mentale qui sont enfin les
dégâts aujourd'hui du confinement sur
sur une ce pays sont considérables
considérable donc on peut pas les
sous-estimer
donc je ne dis pas qu'il ya qu'il faut
ne rien faire mais on ne peut pas avoir
uniquement le nombre de contaminations
peut-être que je vous partage des
commentaires de certains internautes
cet internaute qui nous dit bar resto
ciné salle de sport tous sont fermés
alors que peut-on recombiner 20 laurent
on peut encore confiné fermer les écoles
c'est toute la question qui a en ce
moment est ce qu'on met une semaine de
vacances en plus haut risque
de faire finalement un confinement
toutes formes et les écoles on peut
fermer tous les commerces on peut
interdire aux gens de se promener d'une
région à l'autre on peut leur interdire
d'aller en vacances ont l'imagination
est sans limite dans ce point de vue là
vers de trucs mais l'espagne l'espagne
confrontée à une situation très
difficile qui envisage un confinement
je lisais un article d'un économiste
espagnol qui disait que l'espagne n'a
pas les moyens ils sont arrivés au bout
de leurs ressources ça va nous arriver
aussi abandonné au bout de leurs
ressources de confidentiel finances
2 oui parce que évidemment si on confine
il faut il faut compenser l'effet
économique du coffee l'espagne est en
fait plus que la france
ça me touche beaucoup ça les
comparaisons intéressantes un l'espagne
est un pays on le sait de tourisme de
restauration de service la france aussi
est donc tout ça s'est arrêté entre les
régions frontalières d'une occitanie qui
vous est cher absolument
on a oublié que le but du confinement et
d'aplatir la courbe pas de réduire le
nombre de morts nous dit nous disait
dollars ça c'est une idée qui vous est
cher alexis c'est l'idée du plateau en
tout cas je pense qu'on peut pas se
fixer comme objectif zéro mort ne serait
ce que déjà il ya 2 600 mille morts tous
les ans pour plein de raisons et et
quand on voit ensemble de statistiques
qui nous disent qu'il ya soixante morts
entre 17 44 ans est née du fait du coc
vide et que parallèlement à ça il y en a
dix mille de d'avc 20000 de maladies
cardiovasculaires on se dit bon donc on
ne peut pas avoir comme objectif le zéro
mains après malgré tout l'objectif
tionnel moins possible ça devrait quand
même le bon sens va pas sauter de voir
des gens que les gens m'aiment mais ce
qu'il faut éviter c'est c'est ce que
tout le monde a vu ses sept sellerie
c'est l'engorgement du système de santé
on n'arriverait plus à soigner les gens
que des gens qu'on soigne finissent par
mourir c'est malheureux ça arrive mais
que des gens qu'on ne puisse pas soigner
les gens c'est ça qui n'est pas
admissible et c'est vrai que vu la
taille de nos services de santé nos
urgences c'est un risque
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire
baisser le nombre de contaminations mais
quand on quand on nous annonce des
contre feux des prophéties quand
l'institut pasteur notamment au mois de
novembre nous à nous fait des chiffres
absolument effrayant et les fermanian
macron et s'explique sans doute
aujourd'hui le fait que même à condition
d moi j'attends de voir vraiment d'aider
d'autres chiffrés notamment les chiffres
d'entrée dans les urgences quand on lui
on lui annonce à la devancent que quoi
qu'on fasse on aura neuf mille neuf
mille personnes modélisation
mathématique
oui à chaque fois ça remet pas en cause
ici aussi en cause par ce paradigme par
lequel tout le monde je tout le monde
jure et par la modélisation mètres
seulement
c'est un modélisation il faut s'en
servir et puis il faut savoir la garder
à distance c'était indispensable de s'en
servir mais c'est un peu c'est un
problème classique ça aussi de la
décision et de la d expertise c'est à
dire que les experts produisent ce
qu'ils savent faire des modèles les
hypothèses des projections mais il faut
les considérer non pas comme la
programmation du futur ou la description
de ce qui va se passer mais comme une
information parmi d'autres c'est pas des
prophéties cela dépend en fait des
hypothèses qu'on a appris et du fait
qu'il ne se passe rien pour modifier ces
hypothèses quand on a pris nos
hypothèses ou contre les deux se passe
des choses qu'on n'a pas prévu et bien
évidemment les que tous les belles
courbes qu'on imaginait où les horribles
coupe qu'on avait imaginé forte
heureusement nahd gêne pas vous venez de
me fournir une excellente transition
pour la deuxième partie de ce débat
salut rage et des stages de 2022 je
donne l'arrêt pour d'abord la parole à 7
cet internaute qui nous dit ça prend
huit ans de former des professionnels de
santé voilà pourquoi on n'augmente pas
tout de suite les places en réanimation
ceci dit on a vu par exemple que
certains pays je veux pas dire le modèle
chinois mais enfin on a fait on a pu
faire des hôpitaux de campagne pères
rapide ou comme ça aucune de ces
solutions lan ont été non je pense que
faire passer une infirmière qui est
aujourd'hui une infirmière dans un
service d'urgence mais pas de
réanimation les formations réanimation
s'apprend pas huit ans de faire passer
un soignant qui est qui est dedans
dans une salle de traitement de longue
durée de faire passer comme infirmière
de base s'apprend pas huit ans non plus
donc en fait on peut quand même arriver
à qualifier un cerveau gens ne s'agit
pas de former des médecins réanimateurs
en tout cas pas que des médecins
animateur il ya besoin de lits
d'équipement et de personnel soignant
c'est heureux il n'y a pas qu'au des
médecins dans les salles de réanimation
allez je vous donne la réponse à la
question pensez-vous qu'un troisième
confinement serait respectée je donne la
réponse provisoire puisque vous avez
encore jusqu'à demain pour voter et pour
l'instant c'est le nom qu'ils
l'emportent avec 62% alors ça c'était
sur la question qui est posée sur
twitter mais c'est exactement les mêmes
les mêmes niveaux de réponse sur le site
du figaro où on est un petit peu plus
62,38 % l'autre question qu'on pose la
salle celle là simplement sur twitter
c'est marine le pen peut-elle créer
selon vous la surprise en 2022
en tous les cas la voici créditée de 24
à 26%
si le premier tour de la présidentielle
avait lieu aujourd'hui
donc non seulement la patronne du r'n
progresserait par rapport à son score de
2017 mais elle serait en tête dans tous
les cas à tester donc par l'institut
harris dans son dernier sondage la
question justement qui fait transition
avec la précédente précédente précédent
débat faut-il croire à ce genre de
prédiction mais quand vous présenter les
résultats et vous dit vous avez mille
fois raison si l'élection avait lieu
dimanche prochain
si l'élection avait lieu dimanche
prochain je parierais sur ce résultat
par exemple boyer en plus d'échantillons
et 2400 personnes il est plutôt robustes
je parierais sur ce résultat
ce qui sûr que chacun peut imaginer
c'est que on y est à 15 mois s'est pas
non plus immensément jean 15 mois on est
à 15 mois de la présidentielle
donc c'est un résultat qui commence à
être significatif et qui nous dit
quelque chose à quoi on s'est habitué
moi je suis toujours estomaqué par ces
grands pas que nous faisons sans nous en
rendre compte
l'idée que marine le pen soit souvent
tour c'est plutôt le contraire qui
serait étonnant donc on a quand même
très vite basculer dans un autre chose
elle est en tête à des niveaux qui
étaient les siens avant qu'elle fasse au
moins
vincent s'en souvient à lesterps ce
niveau là quand elle a fini à 20h30
mais les conditions sont pas les mêmes
ça n'a rien à voir la diversité ne sera
pas la même et il y à l'intérieur de ce
sondage
des indications qui sont extrêmement
impressionnante qui atteste de son
enracinement dans une base beaucoup plus
large qu'on ne pourrait s'y attendre par
des indications plus précises sur
lesquelles peut-être on aura l'occasion
de je crois qu'il faut prendre les
sondages plus ceux qui sont pas plus
mais pas moins non plus oui à cet
enseignement intéressant dans ce sondage
et on peut les étudier on va en reparler
après vous avez raison de dire c'est
évidemment pas une prophétie alors denis
vous dites que on n'est qu'à 15 mois
c'est pas très loin avantages des
commandes le souvenir au sun prophétie
qu'on faisait ou que certains faisaient
un an avant une élection
et puis bah si c'est vrai qu'il arrive
souvent que c'est pas comme ça que ça se
passe les gens éventuel état est temps
que sont remontés jusqu'à giscard qui
jusqu'à quelques mois peu de temps avant
l'élection devait gagner puis n'a pas
gagné et on se rappelle le dr le second
tour chirac
hollande qui a lieu notre balladur qui
devait jour à christine lagarde n'est
pas donc bugge balladur qui devait
gagner
chirac jospin qui devait avoir lieu qui
a pas eu lieu enfin bon donc et hollande
hollande sarkozy hollande sarkozy enfin
bon bref
donc il faut quand même être très très
très très très prudent sur ces choses là
j'ajouterai qu'il ya quelque chose qui
devrait nous rendre encore plus près
dans cette affaire de covin je pense que
ce qui rend extraordinairement difficile
à lire la situation
c'est un conte ne sais pas comment va
évoluer l'épidémie médicalement et 2 que
dans l'hypothèse où on n'en sortirait
que moi je continue d'ici la
présidentielle que je conduis
privilégiées on ne sait pas du tout et
moi je serais bien incapable de le dire
comment va une fois que la sphère sera
derrière nous en tout cas en matière de
santé publique mais pas de rien et en
matière d'économie et de chômage
comment va réagir l'opinion est ce que
par exemple mais il ya mille hypothèse
mais est ce que par exemple les français
vont dire robe avec le recul finalement
ce gouvernement il sait pas si mal
débrouillé il a été là et on en est
sorti et il n'a pas tout fait bien mais
si on en est sorti c'est comme un peu
grâce à lui donc finalement renvoyée
sous mac rond il a bien fait le job
c'est possible c'est pas absurde de se
dire ça on est soulagé on trouve que
finalement ils ont pas fait si mal de
boulot mais l'hypothèse inverse est pas
non plus impossible c'est de se dire
mais ces gens mais toute façon pendant
ça fait quatre ans que ça dure et
diriger les journées pielko vide on veut
plus les voir parce que toute façon
chaque fois qu'on les voit on repense au
couvent idée est finie et on s'en
débarrasse
et donc ce scénario-là donges est le le
tous nos gouvernants avec l'eau du bain
parce qu'on ne veut plus de ces années
de malheur il n'est pas absurde non plus
moi je suis incapable de dire
aujourd'hui comment l'opinion réagira
par ailleurs si les bd elle même n'est
pas fini comment est-ce que les gens se
diront allez on fait on fait bloc
derrière les gens qui non seulement sont
aux manettes
parce que c'est on est en perdre encore
de grands périls donc il faut faire
unité nationale où est ce qu'ils diront
ces crétins ont été incapables de nous
soigner depuis deux trois ans maintenant
il faut qu'il s'en aille
tout est possible donc c'est toujours
compliqué un an avant mais avec cette
épidémie moi ça me paraît moi je serais
incapable de dire ce qui va se passer là
je vous propose de l'écouter peut-être
dans des propos qu'elle a tenus
hier et qui étaient liées justement à la
situation on commente après la vente
écoutez je crois aux politiques qu une
technocratie infatué a voulu remplacer
que la facilité poussait à congédier
je crois aux politiques et en ces
circonstances particulières qu'elles
soient technologiques politiques ou
sanitaire je crois à la nécessité de son
retour le temps des gestionnaires des
pseudos sachant et des boutiques et est
finie 2000 se positionne quand même
quand elvis ajustements comme une espèce
d'alternative à ce qui est en train de
se passer actuellement
oui oui c'est amusant qu'elle fustige
les bouddhique et parce que la boutique
c'était quand même l'électorat du front
national pendant pendant des années
c'est la formule est curieuse vous vis
et c'est cette idée que il faut sortir
de ce cadre de ce qui s'apparente à une
gestion technocratique techniques
sanitaires du pays
et inévitablement dans une crise comme
celle là il ya une gestion sanitaire
technique voilà il ya beaucoup de
décisions qui sont prises par la
technocratie parce que c'est un c'est
comme ça que ça marche ça marchera pas
autrement
et donc elle l a bien senti ça c'est une
bonne intuition de sa part et quand on
parlait tout à l'heure d'un risque de
refus ou d'usure du consentement au
confinement
c'est dans ce qu'elle dit est à dire au
fond il faut qu'on reprenne
une action politique et non pas
technocratique alors ça veut pas dire
grand chose dans la réalité
après mais c'est une photo que c'est une
façon de de proposer à son électorat le
retour de la politique qui fait sens
pour les électeurs puisque la politique
c'est eux les électeurs ils peuvent
voter pour le retour de la politique
alors que la technocratie et la science
nous explique que on sait pas donc on
doit attendre les décisions c'est assez
habile
la question qu'on pose justement sur
twitter c'est marine le pen faute elle
selon vous créé la surprise en 2022
alors cet internaute nous dit la
surprise non mais elle pourrait servir
d'épouvantail pour faire élire un autre
candidat comme emmanuel macron en 2017
est ce qu'elle est condamnée selon vous
autant de la situation être le meilleur
moyen de faire gagner ses adversaires
c'est la stratégie depuis je ne je crois
que si sûr est tellement tellement
ouverte
d'abord du fait de l'émiettement du
paysage politique et donc on sait pas du
tout aujourd'hui
vu l'état des forces elle a un coup
d'avancé on semble que le maillot macro
est derrière mais tout ça peut évoluer
la droite pu remonter si la gauche
faisait arriver à s'unir bon c'est pas
fait mais sur le papier si la laci
mélenchon est dans le coup tout ce monde
l'arrivée un poste entend d'ailleurs un
candidat on a quand même on a
l'impression qu'on a un paysage avec
plein de morceaux en alentours de 20%
alors un peu plus pour les uns un peu
moins pour les autres mais un peu plus
on peut arriver un peu moins peut même
arriver un peu plus donc on peut avoir
des configurations de second tour qui
sont absolument différente avec marine
le pen c'est marine le pen avec macron
sans macron avec la droite sont à droite
avec avec un candidat de gauche sans la
gauche gauche écologiste je veux dire
tout ça peut tout me semble t'il tous
produire et donc comme vient se
surajouter à cette incertitude
arithmétique l'incertitude sanitaires et
l'institut de politiques qui la
conséquence des solutions sanitaires
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut
absolument rien exclure
dire que à la gagner parce qu'elle est
devant ça me paraît absurde mais dire
qu'elle ne peut en aucun cas gagner ça
me paraîtrait aussi option il ya une
indication intéressante à ce sondage si
vous faites le total des candidats de
gauche écolo compris ce que ça ferait 26
voilà toute la droite ça fait cinquante
et macro ont fait 24 on ne met pas un
héros d'un jeu par hypothèse grave et 50
un bloc de droite quand même alors on
peut dire que tous les électeurs qui
voteraient pour laver bertrand sont pas
de la même droite que ceux qui votent
pour nicolas dupont aignan mais je sais
pas quel sera le comportement des
électeurs qui ont voté pour mélenchon au
premier tour s'il ya un second tour de
ce type
donc là la situation me paraît m'a quand
même 150 bloc de droite avec avec le
avec leur aide oui bien sûr mais c'est
ça oui donc mais en gros ça veut dire
qu'il ya 25 25 25 côté macro et vous dis
et pour la gauche vous disiez 66 donc on
a quatre cartes donc ça veut dire que
toutes les configurations si les uns et
les autres arrivent à s'entendre sont
positives non non ça veut dire que tous
les candidats de droite font 50 au
second a vraiment ou non au premier tour
et que dans ce sondage
toute la gauche ah oui tous et le fond
mais donc individuellement ils ne feront
pas tous d'accord que je veux dire c'est
que vous avez les rectorats kiwi %
choisir un candidat de droite avec un
second tour il y aura marine le pen face
à emmanuel macron bien sûr comment le
cas comment cet électorat de droite va
se comporter qui est dominant la
disparition de la gauche est
impressionnant d'ici quand même
donc ça c'est un point qui me paraît
impressionnant l'autre point que ce
sondage montre que nous on avait vu dans
notre étude sur quoi il figurera
d'ailleurs sur la protestation
électorale vous en souvenez on avait vu
monter beaucoup le soutien des nouvelles
générations et marine le pen sur rmc
confirme est là elle est en tête 34 % et
de noix premier tour 34 sur le sort du
premier parti ouvrier le 1er mai à deux
soldats un moment non mais mais mais là
ça ne fait que de la ceinture de leur
exemple peut-être pour 110 dans quatre
ans soit franchement ça c'est quand on
regarde dernière remarque je ferais mais
chez les csp + macron fait 33 mais elle
fait 24 lc 24 1 de fellation c'est plus
un changement contre nous ça ou si notre
côté on commence à avoir des catégories
moyennes supérieures qui s'intéressent à
ce vote là et quand vous faites chez les
csp - elle cartonne et la 38 macro est à
16 dont il
ference importante si vous faites le
total des deux indications simples csp +
csp moi elle est à 60 de macron est à 49
dont il ya quand même quelque chose qui
qui est en train de douala ii de se
mettre en route le risque est temps pour
macron du fait de sa position centrale
devoir de décevoir des deux côtés quatre
sortes de gens de gauche ici un second
tour comme on dit aujourd'hui ce qui
n'est pas sûr mais le pen macron que ce
jeune gauche disent non mais macron il
est pas vraiment de gauche il nous a dit
su neutraliser le président des riches
on votera on veut pas de marine le pen
on n'ira pas se déplacer pour voter pour
mâcon l'écart sans nombre de gens de
droite disent ce mac roncq et donner des
gages à la gauche qui finalement ne veut
pas vraiment droite on n'ira pas voter
pour le bâillement n'ira pas voter mâcon
et donc du coup si elle elle fait le
plein avec le maquereau ont surtout avec
juste ses voix de premier tour ça fait
plus grand monde
le premier tour pour un président
sortant partir à 24%
c'est pas beaucoup
un an avant aussi on regardait regarder
dans l'histoire mais les présidents
sortants je parle pas de françois
hollande mais générac d'accord chirac un
an avant il était à 25
non non on est en dessous ouais c'est ça
quelqu'un qui se rapproche de chez moi
cette dernière dernier commentaire qui
est sur twitter de tête qui nous dit on
a tout essayé en france la gauche il lui
il pense que marine le pen ait une
chance il y en a tout essayé en france
la gauche la droite et l'hérault m
et c'est moi c'est juste une hypothèse
autres marques je voudrais vous faire
commenté avant de terminer on lui
rappelle toujours les chèques aux débats
incontestable elle le reconnaît
elle-même le plafond de verre mais
aujourd'hui effectivement on en a parlé
le monde les événements son maintien
dans les sondages et aussi le fait que à
droite personne finalement on n émerge
ou même dans la droite hors les murs on
est un bon test pas mal de l'hypothèse
malvilliers des choses comme ça et c'est
rien n'émerge
donc est ce que là aussi ça peut ça joue
pas enfin en sa faveur 6 même même si on
note également une usure oui de
marie-laure il ya ça aussi
oui d'accord au prix chez les siens qui
voudraient bien avoir une autre maire du
mans c'est justement qu'il y avait cette
usure que même l on disait en a marre
elle pense à bayal etc
mais ce que justement même ça c'est pas
une hypothèse en tout cas elle a cette
fois ci je sais pas si ce sera la der
des der mais cette fois ci elle a
vraiment une carte à jouer
et elle peut soit se gagner moi je crois
que c'est possible je ne sais pas cette
prévision mais je crois que c'est
possible
si le 2 et le 10 on peut pas pas écarté
cette hypothèse elle peut aussi empêcher
une victoire nette et rendre compliqué
le début d'un nouveau mandat
c'est attention là les effets de cette
élection ne se mesureront pas uniquement
qui va gagner et qui va perdre bien sûr
ce qui va gagner et qui va perdre oui si
c'est marine le pen qui gagne mais même
si elle perd va falloir dans quelle
situation se trouve le pays et les
partis politiques qui sont pour les
autres
en tout cas à la ramasse là après on a
vu tout un autre facteur pour qu'on
puisse dire qu'il joue en sa faveur
après il ya effectivement et vous avez
raison le fait qu'elle peut aussi être
assimilée parce que ça fait très
longtemps qu'elle est dans le paysage
par les électeurs au système dont les
gens considèrent qu'il a globalement
failli et si donc au lendemain de la
sphère du coc vide le cas d'espèce d'une
sorte de révolte de l'opinion contre ces
gens qui nous gouvernent ces gens qui
sont là depuis trop longtemps et qu'on a
trop vu on peut dire ça va lui profiter
après tout c'est la seule qui exerçait
le pouvoir mais mais mais elle si elle
fait partie du paysage et les gens
peuvent dire mais celle là aussi on l'a
vu on va en trouver encore un autre moi
je crois que les choses sont très très
très très ouverte est ce qu'on peut dire
après avoir vu à sont deux facteurs qui
qui qui font penser que sa victoire ne
n'est pas impossible même sais pas ce
qui est le plus prévisible les
faiblesses de son équation personnelle
doivent être aussi porté au débit de sa
connaître ya pas non plus d'adhésion ni
d'enthousiasmé on peut aussi se dire
finalement avec tout ce qui se passe
avec tous les problèmes de l'immigration
tous les problèmes liés à la santé
le technocratie qui nous gouvernent qui
n'arrive pas à vaincre cette épidémie on
pourrait croire qu'il pourrait se dire
si le candidat qui représente ses idées
était formidablement attractif on
pourrait se dire il y aurait à une
explosion du vote le pen c'est pas le
cas donc c'est pour ça que c'est très
difficile de pouvoir que ce soit marine
le pen peut-elle selon vous créé la
surprise en 2022 et bien pour l'instant
vous êtes sceptiques fou dit non à 67%
en tous les cas il ya eu beaucoup de
de gens qui ont répondu à cette question
sur sur twitter puisqu'on était à mille
trois cent mille trois cents personnes
ce qui est assez rare sur une question
sur une question twitter quand on a la
moitié estiment déjà que c'est beaucoup
sur l'effet de ce genre de questions
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis
enfin d'avoir des battues et d'avoir
commenter avec nous l'actualité demain
vous retrouver guillaume roquette avec
la gabrielle cluzel de boulevard
voltaire et gilles smadja ancien grand
reporter à l'humanité directeur de
cabinet du maire de nanterre merci à
très vite sur fear alive
[Musique]